hey reject nation
Greg Alva here Johnny we are gonna watch
today from the channel vice news how
movie trailers manipulate you this is
perfect for what we do yeah
also we cameoed in this video when I say
cameo I mean cameo boy can you miss it
underline that word I'm excited to check
this vice man it spice away from the
home box office check it out before we
do that I want to give a patron of the
day shout out to a man named Taylor
Bentley Taylor is from Tennessee
Nashville heir to the Bentley fortune
and he is one awesome gentleman he was
talking with me a lot lately about how
his passion is in music and lately he's
been studying a lot of film this guy is
only 26 years old but he has the heart
of a mature 45 year old physically major
a compliment you need to take care of
yourself and your risk of heart disease
rate your not be a law recently we had a
big heart to heart put up a vlog on
patreon that I'm considering putting a
cut before on YouTube making major
consideration got a little emotional in
there we had a lot of exchange back and
forth and what I love about Taylor he's
not afraid to cry
it takes a real man to cry watch John
cry not a real man Taylor real man laugh
we can cry together buddy
hmm
[Music]
this is gonna be great we're looking for
do this already
everybody thinks it the studio's do the
trailers they have no idea that there's
this entire industry built around movie
trailers in 25 hit its lowest point in
25 years but the movie trailer industry
is experiencing a golden age just over a
century ago premise screened at the end
of films earning them the name trailer
soon they were in front of the movies
and the trailers themselves started to
evolve in the early 2000s about a dozen
companies produce movie trailer park
there are more than a hundred trailer
Wow you go and you seek out particularly
on it on YouTube that one form of
advertising that you want more studies
of the brain have found the connection
between reactions to trailers and a
film's box office success and people
trust trailers more than Rotten Tomatoes
and even their own friends better
spectrums have become their own form of
entertainment right the dissection
process that happens we attended the
trailer industry's version wait not
awesome there's a trailer for two
minutes that will make you laugh cry and
most of all get you to cough up 15 bucks
for a movie Fox Searchlight
that movie a garage there happens in
every single trailer and it's called
sixty voices rising and it goes are you
getting UV intensity you're going up
until that one big shot before you go
into time exactly
there's lots of rice yeah but that's one
of them that's a big one
lots of power downs and bass drops power
down and then you throw an impactful
line in their video steam sounds a view
an explosion you can put in like the
sound of an eagle just to kind of give
it a bigger feel this trailer or baby
driver a woman turns around and in the
backseat of a car and it was just like a
jungle cat that just goes the cool
factor whenever you see somebody
reacting to something on a trailer
that's the emotion that we're trying to
give you so you see somebody crying
shock laughing those are all things that
are being done deliberately when you're
dealing with international a joke that
works really well in dialogue doesn't
translate necessarily so well but a nut
punch that always works yeah especially
for us music and potent ingredients in
an enticing trailer
there are even composers who specialized
in creating the spoke trailer music as
well as juicing up well-known song
realization exists when you play the
originals II know that amazing trucks
they don't necessarily work for the
trailer
[Music]
and then they enhanced it by adding to
the orchestra elements and big drum set
the song didn't happen
while truly radiation seek to enhance
classic treasure a different technique
is recording a song in a way that
completely changes its tone my god
they're coming up recovers covers like
these have replaced the narrated in a
world style as the most widely mocked
trailer-truck even by the man who
popularized it when we did the trailer
for social network that used a cover
song of radiant heads creep that then
became a thing that you started hearing
more and more of like okay no we don't
do that anymore please touch on imagine
dragons as well as countless Harthouse
classic so I think was constantly trying
to find out what the new new thing is oh
wow we did a trailer that used kind of
rhythmic device of the guy's head
getting pounded against the wall
with something like the government we
use the sound of DiCaprio's breath
Nikita hear the sound of his grave being
dug is giving it the counter rythm it's
all about serving the character in the
story I'm now starting to see lots of
things of rhythms and trailers just for
the sake of repeating sounds even even
to watch it yeah yeah very sound design
heavy gun gun [ __ ] left and right
people kicking each other trailer yeah
once it becomes a for me is it you want
to find something else so that oh look
at that movie look what they did but we
don't get too invested because it is
definitely not fine art that is
commercial art every trailer is a
collaboration between ourselves Studios
don't make wanna stand so you are trying
to make a lot of people happy sometimes
we're working a year in advance on the
film which is crazy anyone thinks that
we spend that much time on these things
[Music]
to contend with the expansive and vague
rules of the MPAA a green van trailer is
what you would usually see in front of a
movie it's rated for pretty much all
audiences and is relatively tame blood
is just the big no-no what you do is you
change the colour of the blood to look
like mud that's done in a lot of horror
film
[Music]
way back in Mon you can grunt no
thrusting yep but if it's a red band
whatever you want red band trailers
which can show explicit content
specialize in targeting more mature
audiences they're one example of the
multiple versions of trailers Studios
often create to target different
demographics there yeah these are no
longer just for theaters and televisions
thanks to an increase in online viewing
they now have to be made for a variety
of different platforms including YouTube
Twitter Instagram and Facebook sis's if
you're trying to watch a trailer online
advertising algorithms may note your
interest in trailers and make you watch
a different trailer before your train
which is a six second trailer for the
trailer you're about to watch with
trailers popping up everywhere it seems
like the perfect time to be in the
business but for some the best trailer
is no trailer at all I mean I'll be
honest it's still my favorite
experiences are when I never see a
trailer for a movie or see any bit of
advertising like go to the best crazy
rich Asians that's one of the literally
everything we work on we actually get to
enjoy all these movies without ever
being exposed to movie trailers we done
I think so
all right yeah that it yeah let's watch
a whole documentary right where's the
section unbeliever where's the imagine
dragon section yeah why our trailers
using so much drag in the extended
version there's just a whole point where
they talk to the band they're like yeah
you know we didn't never think we would
be making trailer music but now this
next island which is all trailers
offices do you understand
you won't flower I didn't think anyone
noticed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I'm probably the greatest detective
in the world
[Music]
I think imagine dragons even is hired to
create songs sometimes for trailers I
think it's what that friction song was I
would not be at all so pinning of that
song sounds like you're gonna hear the
mi tune
you had a terrible choice to make in
Berlin if that's on an album comment
below correct us please when was the
last time somebody heard like a complete
imaginary I mean there's a lot to kind
of deconstruct here we haven't done this
segment in a while but it's personally
one of my favorite things to do which is
called trailers revisited and that's
where we basically do a reaction to a
trailer for a movie we've already seen
and then we determine how accurately
portrayed the movie is you know talking
about spoilers tone a whole bunch of
stuff I think this is only going to
amplify knowledge like it's there I want
nothing more than to do a trailer now I
wonder if this sound here is anything
from the movie or if they just put it in
to make it cooler I feel like you and I
are usually pretty good at determining
rarely do we watch the trailer for a
movie and then watch the movie and be
like this is totally completely off from
what we anticipated for the movie even
when it seems like they're trying to
hide stuff yeah we can only easily pick
up on what they're hiding so there's a
couple of facts here that I find
fascinating here I have how they're
saying that sources Trust movie trailers
more than something like Rotten Tomatoes
Ron savannahs according to this chart
wherever this national research group is
the chart here saying that Rotten
Tomatoes is lower than the French social
media posts and movie trailers which I
find surprising I felt like we're on it
Tomatoes plays a big part these days
especially in certain movies you know I
certainly seem freaked out but I feel
like if Rotten Tomatoes and friends
social media posts are in tune with each
other I feel like that plays a major
factor beyond if a movie trailer is
really cool yeah I would have thought
that that friends and family posts would
be number one then Rotten Tomatoes that
movie do you constantly hear people go
like trailers try to sell it to you but
I guess maybe the thing with that is
people trust a friends more than they
trust the critics I guess having the
visuals and the sound from the movie is
never gonna replace the speculations of
people you know who
you know like a guy cuz the trailer is
something I can see and feel with my own
eyes and head so that makes sense yeah
so in a way even if you know not to
trust trailers that much I feel like
it's still easy to be suckered by one
have you heard of the golden trailer
Awards I've never heard of these that's
crazy
I've heard of this III thought trailer
editors people who cut up these trailers
don't get enough credit trailers are its
own type it's like well how the guy put
it here best but we don't get too
invested because it is definitely not
fine art that is commercial art this
level of commercial art is something
that should not go unrecognized
especially if they're saying movie
trailers are the main things that put
butts in seats they deserve a lot of
credit yeah yeah I would like to check
out the trailer Awards be like what won
best trailer yeah and and to see all the
different like Rises and and some of the
different technical terms yes the rise
is something I've always noticed
something we never point out it's just a
common editing trick that they use in so
many trailers
my god it's Megalodon
but when they did this montage of it
like I wonder how much of this
subconsciously has plated affecting to
my brain of loving something to it or
when they point out the the base drop
right before a cool line or something
like that tell me that's a trend I
noticed a whole lot that's yeah yeah you
know like whatever that sounds like
thinking about the way trailers have
come up over the years like I I'm not
surprised that they have awards and
things like that because like it truly
is for as many not great trailers as
there are it is truly impressive on both
a commercial and artistic level when you
can have a trailer that just properly
prepares you for its movie yeah that
really can succinctly sell you something
without making you feel misled or you
know like a whole bunch was missing or
something like that like props to you
know it's not high art necessarily but
props to these people who put these
together and also curse them for the
endless trends that we get yeah and
that's the other thing too is now they
said like there used to be a handful of
houses cutting trailers and now there
are hundreds and I'm sure that that's
part of why there's so much bloat on
some of these yeah yeah cuz you'll get
50 other houses going oh we all gonna
get a somber cover now you know and
that's probably all happening
simultaneously because they make these
so far in advance that was surprising to
me too that they are sometimes working a
really long time on trailer who find
that surprising at all that they that
they work that long on trailers
especially for like the bigger movies -
oh it's not like the Marvel the DC films
I feel like they were a long time in
advance I mean that Aquaman trailer was
seen like to be one of the most reworked
trailers ever yeah a talk that was
around oh we keep pushing the trailer to
keep pushing the trailer we're trying to
prep this trailer to be perfect
and I think that happens with a lot more
movies and we realized yeah I guess it
makes a lot of sense to me now
especially in the last few years the
trailers themselves have their own
audience like trailers drop on YouTube
and blow up all the time and have these
independent lives kind of beyond their
movies especially for tentpole movies
there has to be a lot of reworking
trailers yeah there's got to be a lot of
reading or oh we just got this new
footage in can you do something with it
that's the part I guess I would be
fascinated to learn more about is do
they get like a whole
movies worth do they just get whatever
is on hand and told to make the best of
it or they sort of like here do what you
can with this and then we'll get back to
you later with more footage like I would
be really curious about that side of
things and they also brought that thing
about how though they'll rework trailer
songs to like punch up certain
instruments or ads for an instruments or
even sometimes insert noses on a
transition or a cut I can't tell you how
many times I'll like actually search
specifically for I remember like not too
long ago Pacific Rim uprising trailer
song I would look for the actual version
of that song that was specifically
demonstrated how they did it in the
trailer or even for the Man of Steel
I'll type of a Man of Steel trailer song
and I'll listen to the three-minute
version of the famous score that came
from that movie but it's the
three-minute one that they play in the
trailer yeah like I'll constantly do
that so that trick works on me for sure
they're talking about like the the combo
hits like they're shown close on the
equalizer fast for please frame almost
history the one guy here was saying that
they think that's boring or and not that
cool I like that effect
honestly I've associated [ __ ] if the
thing is it's always like a cool trailer
thing it doesn't really demonstrate the
movie it really translates into the
movie Mission Impossible fall out yeah
[Music]
yeah or when he does this shoot in time
with the music yeah towards the end yeah
or even in Jumanji welcome to the jungle
they rieta 'td the welcome to the jungle
song yeah and then they had some gun
[ __ ] noises go on in the middle of it
you're like oh that was a cool moment so
I think it's effective I think it works
well I think yeah I think more than
anything what they were getting at is
just like when trends start to becomes
you just see the same techniques over
and over again that thing yeah blood I
never noticed that I've never noticed
that oddly enough Kill Bill that I
didn't understand the context of the
time the first time I saw the trailer I
was like it seems weird that they're all
covered in black stuff yeah you know and
yeah it's to have that brought back to
me as some kind of disparate negative
information was a little fast well it
tints the whole Union because you can't
just hit the blood alone I mean I mean
you could can but I've imagined to be a
pain in the ass
yeah I'm also surprised that they didn't
really cover how most trailers have
scenes in the trailers that are not in
the movies or they'll really tweak the
images do cuz that I mean to say to call
your video how movie trailers manipulate
you I feel like that's a major
ingredient I thought this was just an
overview on the trailer industry at the
moment like I would want to have that's
right and I was like oh I felt like
there's so much more - yeah I already
thought what we got was great but I feel
like he could go even deeper we haven't
seen the Slender Man movie big complaint
I've heard from countless people at this
point is there so much trailer footage
that is not that's not in the movie at
all well there's the donee yeah like
that's very manipulative there might be
scenes that really got you or like even
Avengers infinity war that big money
shot of the heroes running which is a
highly talked about moment that's only
shot for the trailer and of course they
don't tell you that it's all the movies
out yeah yeah well especially with
Slender Man like I would I would be
fascinated to hear some specific cases
because then you start to wonder like oh
did they have this footage and then
people came out and they're like this is
a real situation though maybe you should
remove
elements of the plot that harken to a
real-life crime and so maybe that
trailer just existed a while before they
changed all that stuff and they were
like you know what we've spent enough
money let's just ship the trailer right
this doesn't really open up a lot of
fascinating doors into something that's
so weird to focus this hard well I
thought this was a great video and
thanks vice for featuring us for one
second yeah guys I'm really happy about
that yeah that was cool
let's gonna feature-length version is
let's do it now released a trailer for
the trailer movement which they did one
of our lower view videos that would have
been cool yes at an example 3,000 bees
do one for just like a viral sketch that
we watch the trailer alright guys well
thanks for watching what other ways do
trailers manipulate yeah put them in the
console oh you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell or ring the notification a lot of
check us on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is a music video
coverage you love to have you become a
patron eject